foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong wherever you're listening to us or
whatever device you're listening to us
on we appreciate your eyes and ears as
we have a very fun episode today I am
flying solo my name is Mark Ellis for
upcoming tour dates you go to Mark
ellis.live I'm currently in Las Vegas
this week telling jokes at Brad
Garrett's comedy club in the MGM Grand
but it's a big week not just for me
but for an actor who's really On The
Rise that we're going to talk about
today I think he's going to do some big
things in Hollywood this Tom Hanks Guy
Tom Hanks has Pinocchio coming out soon
and then you also have the Elvis movie
that he starts as Colonel Tom Parker in
that is out on your vods on your stuff
like that at home so you can watch Elvis
at home you can go see Pinocchio or you
can listen to this show and you can get
a wide swath featuring The Best of Tom
Hanks because we're running through his
Tomato Meter specifically the top 10 and
what movies we think Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong about being in that top ten what
should be in Tom hanks's top 10 what
movies in there that is maybe just a
little too high there's a great
editorial right now that you can check
out on rottentomatoes.com it's the the
full list and it's all the Tom Hanks
movies it is ranked by Tomato Meter so
it's it's a it's a beefy article but
it's a great great read and so you can
check out the top 10 in your opinion if
you feel strongly about Tom Hanks one
way or the other as all of us do RT
wrong at rottentomatoes.com is what's
written in my show notes I believe our
email address is RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com there it is Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com I just said our email
address five different ways and I'm
pretty sure you're going to be able to
figure out the right one at the end of
this show when we open up the mailbag so
enough Preamble enough yapping with me
we have an incredible guest today who is
a member of the binge boys he's the bad
boy of the binge boys and you also know
him from tournament nerds and screenshot
he's and he's coming up right on the
other side of this Tom Hanks ranking
buckle up everyone we Consolidated the
Toy Story movies it would have been like
half the Tomato Meter top 10 so we
Consolidated the Toy Story movies uh
that is number one according to the
Tomato Meter because you got a hundred
percenters in there number two is big
from 1988 that's 97 certified Fresh
Catch Me If You Can smash guides into
the three spot at 96 percent Apollo 13
is also 96 and then at number five it's
a beautiful day in the neighborhood
95 certified fresh Captain Phillips is
number six at 93 percent it's tied with
number seven Saving Private Ryan and
number eight that thing you do and then
we get to bridge of spies in the nine
spot at 91 certified fresh and then we
finally fall out of the 90 percentile
with number 10 Castaway which is 89
that is your Tom Hanks top 10 according
to the Tomato Meter but now we bring in
that famed writer producer actor
comedian brilliant mind when it comes to
All Things entertainment he is the
co-host of the binge boys podcast the
co-host of Tournament of nerds you love
him from screen junkies you've probably
met him on the street and he's just been
such a swell felony in person he is Hal
Rudnick returning champion good day sir
oh Mark Ellis uh what what an intro I
mean I I I can't follow that how can I
live up to that intro oh my goodness
um what a pleasure to be here what a
pleasure to talk America's dad America's
brother Uncle he's been so much he's
grown up before our very eyes he started
uh on uh situational comedies and he is
now uh in serious spielbergian fair and
everything in between what a pleasure to
be here it's been a lot of phases of Tom
Hanks going all the way back to those
sitcom days not just with Bosom Buddies
I think he popped into an episode of
like I want to say taxi or something
like that and oh he had a very famous
episode of Family Ties that's right it
was like a very special episode because
Tom Hanks it was
um it wasn't straight up comedy like uh
most sitcoms it was some serious dramedy
because he was a problem Drinker on this
episode and and I specifically remember
the scene where he was trying to stay
clean but he went into the kitchen on
Family Ties and he chugged a bottle of
vanilla like the thing that stayed with
me is you can get drunk off drinking
vanilla yeah that's I don't know if he
was an alcoholic or maybe he just had a
a biting sweet tooth that he was trying
to cure in the Keaton family kitchen
with their vanilla extract that is a
deep dive into the early days of Tom
Hanks and let me ask you this because as
you mentioned he's America's everything
to us so we're all fans of Tom Hanks if
you are looking at that top 10 that I
just eloquently to a point read what is
the movie that you feel like
belongs in there but just somehow isn't
now I don't love this movie it's a
polarizing movie but I feel like all
right let me back up the car a little
bit and take like a overview here
the list is missing a lot certain uvras
of Hanks and I'm talking the
light-hearted goofy Hanks from the 80s
which we'll talk about a little bit more
and then
uh conspicuous by their absence his two
Oscar films and they're polarizing in
different ways and we can talk about
that in a moment but I think Forrest
Gump even though I'm not a Forest Gump
lover I appreciate it for what it is
it's uh this guy who's a little
um you know uh neurologically challenged
uh let's say and he's uh not a bright
dude but he spans Decades of History
falling in with the right people
managing to show up at the right place
and you know what it's a little schlocky
it's manipulative but it's also a little
bit of a feel-good romp and didn't it
win best picture it certainly did win
best picture and everybody rails against
it now because it beat out Shawshank
Redemption which everybody watches and
Pulp Fiction that's right so you you
have that movie come out in 1994 and
you're right that was the second of his
back-to-back Oscar wins for Philadelphia
and then Forrest Gump yeah so people
like like rail against Forrest Gump I
feel like you either love Forrest Gump
or you hate Forrest Gump there's very
few uh tweeners on Forrest Gump a lot of
people like I've I ask people all the
time it's this is my Icebreaker hey do
you have a favorite film or what's one
of your favorite movies
um you've been my wingman before before
I got married you and I have been to
many dinner parties together oh yeah uh
and people say Forrest Gump like on the
reg
so I feel like
it is an Oscar uh uh win for him it's
you know it's an iconic film it's uh
some very good work by zemeckis it's got
some great supporting stuff Gary Sinise
didn't he win uh Best Supporting uh for
that he did he was at least nominated
for it and nominated like going to your
point here if you look at the audience
score so if Forrest Gump is 71 percent
of the Tomato Meter still fresh but
nowhere near the top ten Forrest Gump on
the audience score side is 95 so maybe
there is something too Hal rudnick's
claimed that Forrest Gump belongs in the
top ten for me I'm gonna go with another
movie that yeah we don't get romantic
comedy Tom Hanks much in this top 10
either which is surprising because he's
got that Trio with Meg Ryan and a couple
other films sprinkled in yes but I look
at a movie that I really think does
everything right and it gives you Sports
it gives you all the dramatic feels it
gives you some comedy it has all of the
things that you want to see Tom Hanks do
and he does them brilliantly as Jimmy
Dugan the former player now manager of
the Rockford peaches A League of Their
Own which it's still shocking to me it's
81 which is good for most movies but 81
percent just feels low to me and I
believe that belongs somewhere in Tom
hanks's top 10 but when you when you say
hey this movie belongs in the top ten
you got to take something else out so
Hal and I are going to be debating all
of these things we're going to be
weighing back and forth with what should
be in the top 10 with what we think is a
little too high and the reasons they're
in I'm just getting word that Gary
Sinise was nominated as Lieutenant Dan
he lost to Martin Landau for Ed Wood I
believe that was oh yeah uh Landau plate
Bella Lugosi uh fantastic performance
great flick great flick
um speaking of great flicks our expert
review curation manager here at Rotten
Tomatoes Tim Ryan has a segment that we
do every week on the show called two
minutes with Tim and today he's going to
be giving us the scoop as to what some
critic were saying at the time of
various Tom hanks's release take it away
[Music]
reviewed movies are all for Toy Stories
which are among the best reviewed films
in Rotten Tomatoes history Toy Story and
Toy Story 2 are both 100 on the Tomato
Meter Toy Story 3 is a 98 and pulling up
the riers Toy Story 4 at a comparably
measly 97 it goes without saying that
all of them are certified fresh the best
reviewed live action Tom Hanks movie is
big from 1988 which is certified fresh
at 97 with 78 reviews and it has a 78
audience score big is followed closely
by Apollo 13 and Catch Me If You Can at
96 and a beautiful day in the
neighborhood at 95 percent
and just for the record his latest Elvis
in which he plays Colonel Tom Parker is
at 78 all of these films are certified
fresh as well by contrast Tom Hanks
worst reviewed film is the circle from
2017 which is a thriller about a
particularly invasive social media
company it's rotten at 15 with 149
reviews and it has a 21 audience score
you may have already forgotten about
that one so what did the critics have to
say in a fresh review for big Kathy
Burke of United Press International
wrote what makes us all work of course
is Hanks himself who brings a remarkable
authenticity and simplicity to the role
he makes being a kid seem as wonderful
as it was and is scary and confusing too
however writing about the film's cast in
a rotten review for the circle Angie had
a Mashable wrote only Tom Hanks manages
to do anything interesting giving his
avuncular image just enough of an edge
to make him unsettling
so that's a quick overview of some of
the highlights of Tom hanks's
filmography
let's kick it back to Mark who spends a
lot of time contemplating whether video
hockey is in fact a sport
back to you all right and there you go
with some some critical barbs where it's
just you know how I remember my aunt um
was she was in the studio audience of
the David Letterman show I think it was
still the his original Late Show that
would that was like after it was like 12
30 at night 12 30 to 1 30 yeah she was
in the studio audience and Tom Hanks was
the guest
on the show that day and my aunt says
that she's since been won over by Tom
Hanks but she said in the early days she
just couldn't shake the idea that he was
just trying to be like the next Bill
Murray and I found that in odd
comparison but I I don't know maybe in
the time it was something else but we
did see him grow up before our eyes and
initially he was known as a comedic
actor absolutely I mean you go back to
just like some crazy comedic romps like
uh bachelor party bachelor party is
straight up raunchy like you know it's
you know it's almost surprising that
like he came
like he survived bachelor party because
bachelor party is like a very like kind
of dirty like R-rated comedy like he
would never go near that kind of
material and never did since then I
believe uh nowaday but uh you know also
Splash and The Burbs and yeah he was a
real uh comedic actor not not even like
sniffing these Prestige dramas uh the
the Ron Howard Steven Spielberg in
stuff that he's done Post Yeah I want to
get into like where he actually where it
started to make the turn where it's like
you know what I am I can be the best
dramatic actor on the planet right now
so let's kick it off with the music for
movie talk
[Music]
and there we have it so we have the top
10 of Tom Hanks I mean if you start with
the top of the list here how the Toy
Story movies again we combined all of
them one through four because they're
all dominant on the Tomato Meter Toy
Story one and two are at a hundred
percent and then Toy Story 3 falls off a
cliff to 98 and then you have Toy Story
4 which is 97 do you feel like the toy
stories are really that great because I
I feel like they're revolutionary and
great movies and so we sort of combine
everything that they've done for the art
form as well as the entertainment value
and there's your 100 do you think that
they belong as high as they are on the
list of Tom hanks's great movies yeah
the Toy Story especially the first one
game changer it was one of the very
early Pixar films it really expanded our
Horizons as far as animated films and
it's an iconic performance from Hanks
now I am waiting for the gritty reboot
of Woody just in the same way they went
back and did light year uh I want like a
Sergio Leone bloody spaghetti western
where uh Woody or like an Unforgiven
where like Woody's just trying to hang
up those guns but he's got to have one
last ride I would love to see that and
then that's the reason why we got the
toy you know for me the Toy Story and
Toy Story 2 have special places in my
heart but Toy Story 3 I think is the
best of the bunch just because you know
what I was was just I was just thinking
that because you know the pathos at the
end and the dark turn and like you are
fearing for their very lives in that
climactic Scene It ain't just uh he's
got a snake in his boot he might burn he
might go into the freaking furnace Ned
Beatty as a bear I mean maybe as as
scary as Ned Beatty has ever been as
even meaner than when he plays Rudy's
dad and tells him to give up his dream
of playing football at Notre Dame
um he's got a purdy mouth he certainly
did in that classic movie starring Burt
Reynolds as well starring rounds in a
banjo from the 1970s
um we look at this list how and in order
for us to put in something that we
really feel like belongs there like a
Forrest Gump really their own you gotta
take something out so if you're
eyeballing the top 10 movies of Tom
Hanks is according to the Tomato Meter
what's the one that stands out to you is
the sore thumb the one that you're like
okay why is this here maybe it's good
but it doesn't belong with the elite
when you think about Hanks you think
about the heart and just how he lives
inside us he owns real estate he lives
rent free in my heart mind and soul so
uh this this list there's yeah there are
certain issues with it it's a little dry
for my taste it's a little
um one note for my taste it's a little
too
Prestige Hanks uh and and antiseptic
Hanks and you don't have the big swings
the fun I mean I love your pick of
League of Their Own so
um in thinking about the list being a
little too one note for me I'm narrowing
it down to remove it's got to be either
Bridge of spies or a beautiful day in
the neighborhood and I'm I'm I'm
going to go a beautiful day in the
neighborhood for two reasons one I you
know Tom Hanks is Tom Hanks and I think
about Tom Hanks too much while I'm
watching him play Mr Rogers it's a good
performance you're watching Tom Hanks be
your neighbor I'm watching uh yeah I'm
watching America's dad also that film
came out too close to the documentary
and they are forever intertwined in my
mind I don't if you told me a beautiful
day in the neighborhood was the name of
the documentary I would have been like
sure I would have signed off on that and
been wrong what is the name of the
documentary won't you be my neighbor
that sounds accurate yeah yeah see
that's like those two movies they came
like we were riding Mr Rogers fever you
remember the nation was Swept Away with
Rogers fever and like we had not only
did we have these two movies we also had
the Mr Roger animated series uh Rogers
and rogerland we had the Mr Rogers one
hour drama on AMC we had the Mr Rogers
sitcom we had the Mr Rogers porno
um
rogered it it started as a normal Mr
Rogers episode then he just kept taking
on clothes and he never changed into his
sneakers he was kept undressing and it
just it just seduces you before you know
what you're watching now the kiddos are
watching and yeah Mr Rogers manga uh so
I just wasn't as interested in seeing
that movie and and it's nothing against
Tom Hanks because you have performances
like that and and you could even say
that and Elvis to me which is fresh on
the Tomato Meter but Elvis not
threatening in the top ten I believe
Elvis is 78 you you look at the
storytelling style of those movies I
think it was a little surprising to
people the way that he got into these
into these characters and the way that
they wanted to tell the story of Elvis
and Fred Rogers respectively if I'm
looking at the top 10 and I have to take
something out it's it's an interesting
list because I agree with you that it's
it feels cold and a little antiseptic to
not have any of the rom-coms or more of
the broad comedies you do have big in
there at number two at 97 but there's
some movies on this list that I find
endlessly re-watchable Catch Me If You
Can is one of those Castaway is just one
of my favorite movies of all time so I
will put it on record I think Castaway
belongs in the top five not just the top
ten but then there's other movies on
this top 10 that are well made but I
can't go back and revisit them Captain
Phillips was just such such an emotional
Powerhouse I don't know that I can do
that to myself again Bridges spies
um you know Saving Private Ryan my God
it's so well done but it is hard to get
through those movies just because you
have to really emotionally prepare
yourself for what's going to happen
absolutely uh I mean you but it sounds
like you were more affected by those
movies than I was I mean do you need a
couple hours to recover after watching
Saving Private Ryan I'll tell you what I
do need after Saving Private Ryan I need
the double feature of that and then give
me A League of Their Own they both take
place around the same time but this is
true Tom Hanks back in the States and
and as the manager Jimmy Dugan of this
ragtag group of gals who are going to
start playing baseball and it it's such
a wonderful heartwarming movie that is
so funny that gets you in all the feels
and the performance of Tom Hanks there's
a scene in particular in A League of
Their Own when Dottie Henson played by
Gina Davis is gonna quit she's just done
because she says quote it just got too
hard and then Hanks turns back into that
ball player that just wants one more
shot at the plate and he says the heart
is what makes it great if it was easy
everyone would do it and it just I mean
it's it's the kind of speech that makes
you want to run through a brick wall for
this guy and you also know exactly who
he is and he's smart with that Hal
because he knows he's appealing to
Dottie Henson's competitive side whether
she wants to admit that it's there and
and how prominent it is she's trying to
hide it but he knows how to get under
her skin in that moment that's what a
great manager does it just got too hard
supposed to be hard
if it wasn't hard everyone would do it
the hard is what makes it great
then we also get the scenery autographs
the ball for the kid and it says avoid
the clap Jimmy Duke and so we got a
little bit of everything within a a
short time in that film where where
where are your memories of A League of
Their Own are you or do you celebrate it
like I do I do I do I mean the the
entire cast just brings it you Gina
Davis and Lori Petty that big sister
little sister competitive relationship
it's fun to watch and it also it gets
you you feel the sibling rivalry there
Rosie O'Donnell at the height of her
powers Madonna bringing the pain uh
oh what's his name uh I I'm sorry it
escapes me uh the broadcaster who he
passed away he was one of the duo from
Lenny and Squiggy on Laverne and Shirley
he's wonderful there's just so many good
pieces to this movie and Tom Hanks like
you were quoting one of his great scenes
also an imminently quotable film stuff
like uh there's no crying in baseball
come on it's it's freaking great also
you know it's a broad comedic
performance but it's he owns it hard and
it's kind of a nice about face for him
because Hanks is usually a clean-cut
fella but uh Jimmy Dugan yeah he's Rough
Around the Edges he's a drinker
um he's uh you know he's a carouser he's
a boozer a user and a three-time loser I
don't know about all that but yeah he uh
it's a great against type performance
and he he just owns the hell out of it A
League of Their Own so well done
especially when you think about like
it's a true story you have the bookends
in the movie or at least the ending
where um you have some of the actual
players going back and uh yeah a such a
fun flick yeah I I just can't get enough
of crusty Jimmy Dugan when he he's just
mailing this in he walks through the
locker room and he takes the longest p
in cinema history maybe rival that with
Austin Powers and yes when he's yelling
at Stillwell the little kid who's
annoying everybody he's just Tom Hanks
is underrated as a yeller he's got this
growl when he yells that because he can
just deliver a line normally but when he
yells when he gets mad you just hear a
little bit of gravel in it and it plays
so well for a character that just his
entire being is that five o'clock shadow
that you see with Jimmy Dugan he's got
that Hannah bar bear a beard that he
just owns because you know he woke up
like that and he had a rough night
before
um your movie Forrest Gump the scene
that gets you about Forrest Gump what is
the what's the scene that really has all
that that magic that special sauce that
you say this is why Gump is unfairly
maligned just because it came out the
same year as his Shawshank Redemption
and it was almost too popular for its
own good the soundtrack's amazing what's
the scene that Hal Rudnick says that's
why this is a great movie when I think
about Forrest Gump there are so many
pockets of Forrest Gump that are
memorable you've got run forest run
where he grows up and the leg braces
come off and he runs across the football
field and he keeps running and then he
catches the kickoff when he's in college
and he keeps running and then he runs
across America come on and then you have
the schlocky memorable scenes except
they're schlocky but we quote them to
this day life is like a box of
chocolates forget it ever I say that
still and then you've got the ping pong
scene there are too many memorable
scenes and then
Gary sinise's character what
a fun
antidote to Forrest Gump uh Lieutenant
Dan is dark he's he's jaded of course
he's you know a wounded in action
um he's uh spending his life in a
wheelchair now and you have you know his
dark point of view versus Forrest Gump
that's really fun to watch unlikely Pals
and then Bubba man
and that you know the scene where he's
listening throughout the course of their
time in basic training and in Vietnam
together all of the different ways to
prepare the shrimp and now we have
America's Finest seafood restaurant
shrimp where you and I go once a month
at Universal CityWalk to uh get drunk
and and uh enjoy peel and eat shrimp
they do have good specials there during
the week if uh you happen to pop into a
bubble gum now they know it's by name so
they just yell it's how and mark But
even before then some pretty good two
for ones but so I would say uh there
there are just so many that stamped this
film as iconic and then Robin Wright uh
you know uh it's her character uh died
of AIDS or HIV in that film I I believe
and I was going to ask your take on
Jenny is she just using Forest because I
I still feel Lake Forest was just being
strung along by her until she really
needed him when she knew she wasn't
going to make it and then she just like
she's like I need to pawn my kid off of
somebody because I may not pull through
this one and so then she warms up to
Forest so I I do feel for Forest but I
still feel like the other side of me
says look
um I I'm roofing for Forest my his whole
life but even Jenny
um even in what's called her an injured
Jenny who's not going to be with it for
that long still probably the best
relationship that guy's gonna find so oh
yeah I I don't know but I don't know how
I feel about Jenny using him the way she
did yeah no she definitely uses him uh
let me put it in terms the kids
understand here Forrest Gump is simp oh
boy Gump is simping on Jenny and he
needed to uh pull himself together and
uh move on rather than just uh you know
be a patsy for her or whenever uh she
needs a ride to the airport you also
have Forrest Gump and I always looked at
Forrest Gump as a story of Hope and I
think the message is and it's a you
can't go too deeply into this because we
know that Forest is for lack of a better
word uh more simple but I feel like the
the message that movie is hey you're
overthinking your life you're using your
brain too much just turn it off and just
let life kind of blow you where it blows
you and just be a feather where if I if
you and I are sitting down how and we're
trying to plan our run for the day
um we might say hey I can't go that far
because my legs aren't gonna aren't
going to carry me I don't have the
endurance to do it farce doesn't really
have that Governor he doesn't really
have that and so he's like I'm just
gonna keep on running and he does and he
just keeps on running and he just keeps
on playing ping pong and he's great and
he's he's successful at whatever he does
he played for Bear Bryant at Alabama so
this is the kid who grew up with brace
on his legs and all of a sudden he's the
fastest runner in the state and so I
feel like the message that movie is that
maybe we're just overthinking our lives
a little too much yeah I think you
summed it up but the one thing I don't
want to gloss over here Mark which is
you what makes you one of the greats
which makes you a tactician could you
pronounce running the way you did
moments ago so the Forest Gump of
vernacular yeah Forrest Gump uh he just
started and then he just decided to keep
on running I love that I love that
that's beautiful it's one of my favorite
scenes to be honest with you that's one
of my favorite Forrest Gump scenes is
just the way that The Jackson brown run
on empty tune kicks in as he continues
to jog across the country and then you
you also have that fun winking nod where
he gets uh mud splashed on his face and
uh and he's Towing off and then he says
it happens and he's stepped at poo and
then the guy gets the idea for the the
for the T-shirt uh have a nice day and
then you also have the it happens bumper
sticker all within that uh quick scene
and so I just feel like the movie is
ushering us through these Trends in
America through the last 50 years and
that was one of the the fun more lighter
but also more memorable moments of that
movie absolutely you know he he Forrest
Gump he he you know he was uh the zelig
of his time he showed up in various
places here there everywhere and uh yeah
you summed it up like the feather now I
have in the notes that that are
wonderful
um producers Lucy Bruckner and Brian
Perez put together and I guess Brian got
it in his head that I being a stand-up
comic myself hate the movie punchline I
don't hate the movie punchline I
appreciate the message that it has about
Sally Field coming from obscurity and
just climbing the ranks and I but I feel
like it's not the most accurate it's
sort of like I go back to Rudy it's like
the real story of Rudy isn't necessarily
like it plays out in the movie although
I do love watching the movie same thing
with punchline not every comedian gets a
Locker at every comedy club we don't
really have a room where you go and give
a pregame speech to yourself but it is
fun watching him do some riffs because
the backstory of punchline is much more
fascinating than the movie Itself by the
way that movie's fresh at 60 percent
um every comedian real stand-up comic
that worked on that movie Damon a young
Damon Wayans is in it Taylor Negron a
bunch of actual Comics Barry Sobel and
they all say that Tom Hanks was so good
so quickly because he was really going
around New York City doing stand-up to
prep for the role he got so good so
quickly they said that if this was what
he wanted to make his trade his life
that he would have been one of the great
comics of all time I'm not saying that
he should have stuck down that path now
I think being a movie star worked out
okay for him but you hear that the rave
reviews from real stand-up comedians I
mean it's mind-blowing yeah uh and then
conversely
Sally Fields character and uh they've
been co-stars couple of times obviously
Forrest Gump she was his mom
um there's probably another one in there
that I'm forgetting but the uh
not that accurate how someone could just
like you know step uh step out of the
living room step out of the dining room
and onto the stage and then boom you're
the darling of late night television and
uh making it her glow up was pretty
significant and fairly quick in in that
movie especially because she had John
Goodman as just this this husband who
just refused the letter really leave the
house at all he was so upset that she
was sneaking out at night to go do
stand-up but then there was a
heartwarming scene at the end where
they're showcasing for Johnny Carson and
hangs and Sally Field both have great
sets I honestly can't remember who wins
the shot on The Tonight Show but John
Goodman finally is in the crowd he's
gonna go see his wife and he's laughing
hysterically at her set and I do find
that it still brings a smile to my face
that she won over her boorish backwards
thinking husband who again just thought
A Woman's Place was the kitchen into
nowhere else and he went out to see her
at a comedy club and she crushed so
congratulations to Sally Field yeah
Sally Fields walked she walked so Mrs
maisel could run I'm saying you go back
and watch it she's just feeling out
material it's a very it's a very similar
style of delivery that Rachel Brosnan
has to Sally Fields character in that
movie so maybe some inspiration was
taken from that if you're looking at Tom
Hanks movies that that just missed the
mark for whatever reason what's the
worst Tom Hanks movie that you've seen
did you go bonfire the vanities do you
go is it one of those Da Vinci Code
movies where he's got interesting hair
what is the movie that Hal Rudnick says
Tom why Say It Ain't So oh that's a
that's a good question so one film that
I thought was
oh oh you could tell it was a bit of a
pandemic film and it felt a little by
the numbers and everything was just very
convenient it's the the movie Finch
where he builds the robot uh to uh take
care of his dog I just felt like there
were too many unexplained things that it
just really happened like clicked into
gear by happenstance like oh he was so
close to eight creating AI artificial
intelligence doesn't exist but he was
able to crack the code with uh basically
the way uh
Tony Stark built his robot uh built Iron
Man in a cave he built it with scraps
and a cave practically uh he he built a
robot that was capable of artificial
intelligence so Finch left me kind of
cold a more recent one uh a year or two
ago on Apple uh that's 74 on the Tomato
Meter and another movie that I didn't
even realize was fresh because it felt
like it got panned at the time of its
release was the 2012 uh flicked on by
the wachowskis Cloud Atlas which people
have feelings on it's 66 so it's fresh
and it's also been listed as Tom Hanks
himself saying that was one of his
favorite movie experiences because he
got to do so many different roles inside
of that so it may not be his favorite
movie that he's ever done but he
certainly had a great time working on it
yeah and you know it's from like the
Beautiful Minds of the wachovski
siblings and it is uh you know I feel
like that's another polarizing film some
people are ready for that journey and
some people are like whoa this is a
little weird One More film uh from Tom
Hanks that I'm uh I feel doesn't hit
doesn't hit right for me Polar Express
Polar Express wow uh I find it to be
nightmare fuel Tom I think Tom Hanks is
so off-putting in the animated version
is it The Uncanny Valley is it just the
eyes it is The Uncanny Valley oh and
then okay now that I've had a moment to
ruminate on it uh one more that I that
really I'm I think I'm an outlier when
it comes to this film I thought Road to
Perdition was a slog I'm not a road to
petition okay and um we talk about
that's the one film for me actually Mark
where I didn't buy Tom Hanks as this
gangster I didn't buy Tom Hanks uh in
that role whereas you know we talked
about how he was kind of against type in
A League of Their Own and he's got a
great
um you know he's got a wide variety of
types and parts and
um pockets in his career but yeah I was
I really thought Road to Perdition was a
snooze I put it on recently I usually
fall asleep to the movie if I'm being
perfectly honest but I don't think it's
it's a bad movie necessarily because I
mean come on you got Paul Newman you
have Daniel Craig and obviously you have
Tom Hanks like it's uh there's some star
power there uh Jude Law so it's
interesting watching particularly Daniel
Craig it seems very unhinged in the
movie which is a treat to watch but it
is definitely one of the slower ones it
did make over 100 million dollars when
it came out in 2002 and it's 81 on the
Tomato Meter
um I I feel like when we talk about the
romantic comedies that Tom Hanks is in
it's one of the legendary sort of
achievements that he's got this Trifecta
of movies with Meg Ryan he's done some
other ones like he had Larry Crown which
was only 37 but him and Julia Roberts
always fun to see them together but Joe
Versus the Volcano I think in retrospect
now is looked at it's just this weird
fun experimental little quirky
one-of-a-kind unique movie 66 percent
but the thing that continues to bug me
about Tom hanks's filmography according
to the Tomato Meter here is that
Sleepless in Seattle is only 75 percent
certified fresh but how is that movie
only only 75 and then you've got mail is
69 I find these to be
um legendary rom-coms from the 1990s I
love the time stamp that you've got mail
is at the dawn of the internet age and I
love Sleepless in Seattle just because
this guy has been through the ringer you
know and then just to have this the your
kid facilitate it's one of the few
movies Hal because you know me pretty
well in real life one of the very few
movies where I say you know what maybe
having a kid wouldn't be so bad
yeah and like literally we we say he's
America's Dad but he grew up in front of
our eyes the crazy comedies and then the
prestige like oh he's growing up and
then oh he's looking for love and these
romantic comedies and now he is oh he's
been there for us it's such a clear
trajectory uh so man I feel like I want
to represent every era in the perfect
Tom Hanks list if I give you let's do
some goats real quick then if I give you
the best Tom Hanks rom-com which way are
you leaning you go and sleep is in
Seattle are you going well terminal
where where would big uh would that go
be rom-com or just straight up comedy I
would put big as a as a romantic comedy
I'll give you that and and and splash is
another one that splashes unfairly
maligned on the splash is actually it's
so it's confounding because even the
audience score is rotten but Splash is
fresh at 91 and so the score is rotten
yeah they just they it was too the world
wasn't ready for mermaid films until The
Little Mermaid came along in 89 is what
I think man uh yeah uh Daryl Hannah at
the height of her powers and didn't we
have John Candy was John Candy and John
Candy and Eugene Levy I believe and
Eugene Levy yeah so uh directed by Ron
Howard right uh so much good work with
Howard and Spiel like you put you put
Hanks with like these old school
Hollywood studio guys and you got magic
you got magic I'm telling you uh
big is your favorite rom-com I'm gonna
go save this in Seattle because I feel
like the song uh that when I fall in
love is one of the best rom-com songs of
all time but if there is a song a piece
of music that accompanies a Tom Hanks
film that will still emotionally
resonate with me how I'm going back to A
League of Their Own and Madonna's This
Used to Be My Playground just hits me
like apologies to Miley a a wrecking
ball it kills me it's just such a great
song and it instantly takes you to
whatever place that you were as a kid
that's no longer there the same way for
me it was Kiwanis Park in Williamsburg
Virginia This Used to Be My Playground
it gets me every time you know back to
Big it's you know I want to represent it
I I might go as far as that's a big song
in in big oh Chopsticks the the scene in
FAO Schwartz iconic but you know what
scene I keep going back to when I think
about big that really
exemplifies childhood it's like it
epitomizes like that point of view if I
could do anything if I was on my own and
had resources the Oreo cookies the Oreo
cookies in the hotel room licking the
the the the the the the the the cream
the Oreo uh filling out and just leaving
all of those discarded uh Oreo halves
man that
Hank's Just Nails it he cuts to the
quick of childhood it's such a brilliant
performance I think and it's so nuanced
because he's playing uh it's a very
difficult complex character and you are
along for that ride and you believe it
it's so well acted so when I said best
rom-com I I think of big as just like
this this force of nature it is fun it
is it is a comedy but it also it gets
you right in the solar plexus with the
emotions so there's so it I think big is
a Transcendent film when you really
think about it the problematic
relationship aside yeah there's still a
lot of great memories watching Big it's
never been one of my go-to's for Tom
Hanks but I am also maybe a little bit
of a weirdo because like I said before
Castaway is possibly my all-time
favorite Tom Hanks movie I think it's
between Castaway and A League of Their
Own Castaway is sort of my fantasy like
even when I'm going when I'm laying down
in my bed at night and I'm trying to
just like relax and go to sleep I
actually think about if I was in a plane
crash I don't want anybody else to die
necessarily but I want to be on that
life raft and just on the waves there's
a storm and for whatever reason it just
calms me and I go into this whole thing
where I think about then I'd wash up on
shore how would I survive for a little
bit and oddly that makes me fall asleep
Hal what is wrong with Mark Ellis yeah I
mean if I crashed I would just uh beg
for the sweet release of death I would
not have the fortitude
um you're not fighting for this for the
survival nope uh uh tell tell everyone I
love them but I will say you know you
you you're on to something here mark
because when you think of great Tom
Hanks movies here's the question is it a
movie that Tom Hanks is in just any
movie or is it the Tom Hanks vehicle and
as Tom Hanks Vehicles go Cast Away you
got Hanks hankson around like nobody's
business like it is all Hanks it's
wall-to-wall Hanks it's nothing but
Hanks and Cast Away it really he gives
you all the feels and he really he just
drives that he drives that car for the
entirety of the movie it is all him and
he owns it that's what it it has to be
uh up there I agree it's a top five
Hanks film will you talk about Tom Hanks
and the roles that we love him for there
are some famous roles throughout history
that Tom Hanks had been considered for
before either he opted out or decided to
go uh the studio started going another
Direction how did they not cast Hanks so
Michael Keaton decided to not come back
for the third Batman movie Tom Hanks was
offered the role of Bruce Wayne in
Batman Forever but he turned it down get
this he was also up for the role of Andy
Dufresne in Shawshank Redemption Phil
Connors in Groundhog Day Jerry Maguire
and Jerry Maguire Mahoning Police
Academy which I think he would have
knocked out of the park here's the one
here's the two here's my two favorite
ones though he was up for the role of
Jack traven and speed Keanu Reeves's
character whoa and past and then the one
that makes so much sense in retrospect
we talk about Meg Ryan being the queen
of rom-coms and America's sweetheart Tom
Hanks was originally looked at to be in
When Harry Met Sally
wow yeah so he would go on to be in Joe
Versus the Volcano instead
some some wild stuff there I could not
see him in speed I could not see him I
just can't picture that no I mean the
way that Keanu plays it I get more see
Tom Hanks as like Jeff daniels's
character who's just kind of yeah and he
got shot and uh he's just wise cracking
into the mic while Keanu Reeves is doing
all the hard stuff but it's uh it's
fascinating to uh to think what might
have been with Tom Hanks but I think we
got some pretty good stuff the post 88
by the way is just an all-time more more
recent Tom Hanks Banger as the kids say
um how uh I'm just gonna reiterate this
to the audience if we're doing a Fantasy
Draft to Tom Hanks movies your number
one pick is big
you know what I'm really leaning towards
Big because you get to see him really
strut his stuff acting wise you have the
early vibrant comedy stuff and then you
could see there's a little more going on
with this guy he's got big things laying
ahead kind of the same way uh you watch
Brian Cranston and Malcolm in the Middle
and it's like oh uh the dad he's got an
inner life going on he could do more uh
you get those feels with Tom Hanks and
yeah I big I just I love it from uh my
childhood and I think it really just
resonates in so many different ways yeah
I gotta go big yeah Apollo 13 is way up
there for me he's so great as Jim
Catch Me If You Can is one that that is
so high in the Tomato Meter I know that
we talk about it with quite the same
reverence as a big or a Castaway that
thing you do is also just a wonderful I
think such such a a time capsule movie
where you really do feel like you're in
that period in the early 60s but yeah my
my number one pick would still be
Castaway so Hal wins the Tomato Meter
around as far as picking the highest
rated Tomato Meter films big at 97 which
puts it at number two according to Tom
Hanks The Toy Story movies collectively
being number one and then mine Castaway
rounding out the top 10. all right Mr
Rudnick it is always a pleasure to spend
some time with you to talk about the
hangs I will talk I will talk anything
and everything with you Mark Ellis I'll
talk comic books I'll talk baseball I
will talk Washington commanders football
uh any any Mark Ellis is good Mark Ellis
uh and it's uh just uh been a pleasure
to uh to know you and enjoy your company
for uh geez getting close to a decade
now getting close to a decade now and uh
football season upon us as of this
weekend in the NFL so that's very
exciting and keep your eye Pinocchio
we'll see where it goes with that maybe
we'll have Hal back once Pinocchio is
released and we have some time to digest
it and we can talk about where that may
rank on Tom hanks's Tomato Meter Tom
Hanks as Geppetto in the upcoming
Pinocchio and you can catch Elvis now
wherever you enjoy movies at home so Tom
Hanks always at the Forefront of our
mind you know Tom Hanks just to put a
button on this he is so America's father
that at the beginning of the pandemic
he's the one to let us know it was going
to be okay even if you get coveted God
forbid he survived from a member he was
like the first Monster celebrity it was
Chad Hanks delivering the news to us
that Tom Hanks had gotten coveted and so
him and Rita Wilson they they
quarantined in Australia I believe and
we were so concerned for a couple days
and then Tom Hanks rebound and we said
all right we're going to get through
this together so thank you for healing
us as a nation and as a world once again
Tom Hanks how where can everybody find
you out there on the social media the
stuff you're working on you have so many
great Endeavors projects the podcast is
binge boys the live show Tournament of
nerds where do we even start with you
sir sure uh well if you uh have a Roku
or Pluto TV you can catch me on
America's Funniest Videos fail Center
hosting a sports center style show where
we are giving a play-by-play of the
library of America's funniest videos
clips uh it's a good time fail Center uh
on your AFV Roku if you can find that
folks and otherwise
all sorts of stuff and you keep up with
it by following me on the social medias
at halrutnik on Twitter and Instagram
and if you uh if you twitch uh maybe you
should see someone about that but you
can find me on Twitch twitch.tv slash
halrutnik that is the iconic Hal Rudnick
a gentleman and a scholar and an
all-around Entertainer he writes he
produces he acts he directs he tells
jokes he does it all kids and I am just
here trying to keep up with him for
upcoming tour dates Mark Ellis dot live
I'm in Vegas right now for another
couple days and then I got some Road
dates before a Big Show in Los Angeles
in December so for jackwood Coley for
Brian Perez for Lucy Bruckner for the
whole gang here at Rotten Tomatoes I am
merely Mark Ellis saying there's no
crying in baseball
[Music]
foreign